mit einer zündenden rede kannte es
sondern trump gelungen sein den
wahlkampf wieder spannender zu machen in
den usa der amerikanische präsident
wandte sich in einer 70 minuten langen
ansprache zum höhepunkt der republikaner
convention an die amerikaner er machte
seine argumente laut warum er weitere
vier jahre verdienen würde
im oval office donald trump stieß hier
wie ein leitfaden immer wieder sehr
patriotische motive an er sprach von der
größe amerikas vom patriotismus vom gott
glauben dieses landes und von optimismus
der amerikaner das neue kapitel in der
amerikanischen geschichte schreiben zu
können harte angriffe gab es auf seinen
demokratischen widersacher joe biden der
wäre eine marionette der radikalen
linken ein trojanisches pferd für den
sozialismus unter einer präsidentschaft
von joe biden würde amerika abgleiten
ins chaos und indien in die anarchie
warnte donald trump es ging ihm bei
dieser rede vor allen dingen auch darum
die wahl zu einem referendum über joe
biden zu machen und nicht über seine
eigene doch durchwachsene bilanz im oval
office das war eines der größten ziele
von donald trump joe biden zu definieren
ihn praktisch so scharf zu attackieren
das eher unattraktiv wird für die
amerikanischen wähler ob ihm das
gelungen ist dem präsidenten werden
jetzt die umfragen natürlich zeigen klar
wurde auch bei dieser viertägigen
virtuellen republikaner convention dass
man ein weicheres image von donald trump
zeichnen wollte es waren auffällig viele
afroamerikaner am redepult und auch
frauen
man möchte hier offensichtlich
wechselwähler in den suburbs motivieren
doch bald trennt wiederzuwählen
besonders frauen diese taktik war
offensichtlich bei dem
republikaner parteitag und eines
natürlich ist klar donald trump hat den
heim vorteil als amtierender präsident
er verwendete das weiße haus als kulisse
für seine rede und für weite teile des
parteitages am ende gab es einen
opernsänger der von der balustrade des
weißen hauses sagen es gab ein feuerwerk
alles sehr bunte spektakuläre bilder
durch die sich donald trump erhofft in
den umfragen aufholen zu können klar ist
der wahlkampf die heiße phase ist jetzt
eröffnet und amerika und die welt
rechnet mit einer schlammschlacht